hey wow thank you I was just gonna tell
you a quick story which is uh I've
always had this lifelong fear of bears
and a few years ago I attempted to face
his fear my sister Patty and I went to
Alaska which I highly recommended and we
went to a place why not
we're do a place called Katmai National
Park that has so many bears that when
you arrive they take you to what's
called bear orientation and they teach
you and I'm not kidding that if you ever
see a bear walking towards you you're
actually supposed to clap and make the
bear aware of your presence like I'm
right here bear I'm right here I'm Mike
and you're a bear and when they told me
this I was like oh I'm gonna be murdered
by a bear because that seems like
basting yourself and barbecue sauce is
fantastic I've applied condiments so
that I'll be last by hand well patty a
night went fly-fishing I don't know if
you've ever tried this but it's much
more difficult than it looks in a river
runs through it
we're waste even water we're in the
rubber pants you know they're called
waders and there are salmon jumping out
of the water in front of us literally
jumping which is what I would do if I
were a fish that seems like a great
field trip you're in the boring water
all day and all of a sudden you're like
[Music]
grow legs and become a human which is
what happened over time
sorry homeschoolers but this salmon are
jumping out of the water I can't catch
them with the rod there's this whole
kind of conductor maneuver of
fly-fishing if you don't catch it you
feel like an idiot you really I should
have brought a net because they're just
jumping that'd be a lot easier we're
we're with this fit the fishing guide
this professional fishing guide and he
feels bad for me because I'm so terrible
so he catches himself places the rod in
my hands and goes you got one that hurt
you know because I knew I hadn't well
here's where it heats up I'm with this
professional fishing guide my sister
Patti's about 75 yards behind us and I
hear her say Mike and it was a voice of
someone who's about to be mauled yeah
yeah had a very distinct pitch you know
it was like ma hey right here she
thought there might be a bear right here
like if you knew the whole time I'd just
be like I turn around there's an 8-foot
brown bear walking towards her in the
water very surreal cuz he wasn't running
you know it wasn't like I will murder
you
Rob it was just like I'm a bear etcetera
well here it was my greatest fear in my
entire life and I was proud of myself
because I built up the courage to say
guide do something
and the guide snapped into action he
sprinted over in the water and he goes
yeah yeah and the bear walks away
alright I'm a bear etc and it was very
relieved that my sister didn't get
mauled but in retrospect I was a little
angry at the guy I was like you know you
didn't tell me about the haha plan you
just told me to go right here
my name is Mike is like he gave me the
bad parachute everybody chute goes off
and I have the multicolored gym class
parachute except build team skills all
right now you go under all right thanks
[Applause]